[Music]
okay just got done seeing one caller
missing lanes which was a was an
animated movie was stop-motion and CG
mixed together and when I was first
watching that I was like man that
animation that looks a lot like
stop-motion they got that right
turned out it was stop-motion yeah I
didn't I thought was fake stuff yeah
yeah the puppets looked to be like
little 6 inch 7 inch figures kinda like
back in the day with Jack Frost yeah
yeah you know that's that's what it was
kind of bringing me to look good the
story itself was actually just kind of a
classic British in adventure exploration
movie along the lines of say like
Journey to the Center of the Earth and
landed time for God and the Sinbad
movies it's like that but with a more of
a comedic tone it also you could
probably throw in a little bit of
Indiana Jones and you can fly throw in a
little bit of early 2000s era Laura
Croft Tomb Raider videogames it was
about justice British explorer slash
cryptozoologist who's trying to he said
he made this bet with a guy in this club
that they have this Explorers Club made
a bet that he could find sasquatch so he
goes to Washington State the United
States he does find sasquatch turns out
he's a regular guy kind of soy boy and
he tries he asked him to get him out of
the you know ask the explored to get him
out of here get him to his own kind
he's his last of his kind he wants to go
hang out with the yetis in the Himalayas
so they go on an adventure to get taken
to shangri-la
you know and it doesn't really work out
it's a pretty good flick parts of it had
just taken place in the Victorian era so
when he gets in America so it's a
Western also yeah during that time it
has you know gunfighters for hire in it
and it's pretty good I thought would you
think yeah I really liked it a lot I
mean honestly the animation is amazing
this is the same studio that did come
over two strings which I think it was a
mouse cursor was dominating yourself a
couple of years back so it's kind of a
similar to look to that I also really
really liked because I love that like
old Victorian like cabinet of
curiosities kind of look or it's like
you know he said he has like all this
stuff in his office like a dodo like all
the books and all this [ __ ] and just
like the way they did everything like
looks really really amazing voice acting
was really good I think it was Hugh
Jackman who was the main character the
Sir Lionel I think it was Zach
Galifianakis what's up Susan yeah
they're not really a kids movie actually
there was a lot of adult undertones and
things that kids wouldn't pick up on
transsexual yeah I was actually gonna
say that it's not like you know like
some animated movies you know like you
know Pixar movies or something like that
are very much English kids this but not
really if you would enjoy it but yeah
it's my I think adults and really pick
up on me Lois Lane yeah it's not really
zany like you know same way that like a
Pixar movie trailer looks name look like
anyone
doesn't really like that it's more like
a classic British yeah and it's like a
lot of good like revolves around the
characters like their relationships with
each other so there's like a lot of like
you know character interaction and stuff
so there's not there's not like a lot of
like wacky crazy [ __ ] all the time it's
very slow-moving like very slow-paced
and it's like Jeff just just you know
the the way they you know they're
traveling around the world and it's just
like these really beautiful yeah I
wanted to mention that you're remind me
had a lot of a 60s movie that had a
couple that had a little bit of a
musical numbers and it was called the
great race remember the great race it
reminded me of the movie the great race
yeah thing is it lacks the musicals
yeah but it didn't need musical numbers
I mean there's humor in it but the humor
is like very understated yeah then I
actually really liked it depended on the
scene some of the scenes were was the
senior they know this but yeah there was
like fights and you know shootouts it
yeah it is each scene kinda is pretty
effective and what it does the action
scenes really did seem like me there was
something to lose yeah but see when the
ship was flipping and they were doing
that she is amazing and the gun
gunfighter was shooting this she's like
oh no these big broad waves or there or
they're up in the Himalayas and they're
hanging by the skin of their teeth in
the side of the road yeah it was like I
liked it I thought it was gonna be a
great movie the the very ending I didn't
really like the way the endings went but
it was still a good movie
yeah it's suburban expectations I hate
that [ __ ] like he didn't get the girl
when I thought that was gonna happen
they didn't have to happen but I thought
it was gonna have well I think like I
said
you know that happens in like pretty
much yeah then there was looked like
there was some messaging there looked
like they tried to say the British
explorers were a bunch of bunch of
[ __ ] that they were just selfish
guys and well not that but it looked
like that's what they were trying to say
that's kind of how I took it was talking
about you know talking about but so I
didn't you know I didn't think that was
a cool thing to say but other than that
was pretty good like I said not not a
kids movie in the same way that some
animated movies are I mean you know you
can watch it but adult oh I think it is
oh yeah yeah okay
you
okay we just got done seeing RiffTrax
live which is one of these things where
the guy that some of the guys from MST
3000 forgiver seen that show they're in
a theater and it's right there in a
theater in nothing is in Nashville
Nashville Tennessee in a live stream a
show of them riffing on a b-movie
in this case it was a B movie called
octa man misspell a
octa which is about a [ __ ] octopus
man it doesn't make any [ __ ] Santa a
terrible movie this hilarious though it
was funnier it what do you think oh yeah
I love I love this and I gotta tell you
because rip tracks live they do probably
about four of these a year that usually
a live stream from Nashville I used to
go to a bunch of them but for some
reason until just this time they always
just showed them at like some theater in
like winter park which is like 20 or 30
yeah and it's like so for a long time we
didn't go to them so like man I'll drive
all that way it's like why did they do
it at our close theater and this was the
first time that they did it ever closed
theater and I was super excited was it
AMC before um yes it was but for some
reason the only one they had in Orlando
was like over by University of Central
Florida that's like kind of far yeah so
so I really hope that they start doing
in them at this data yeah what's up tag
during it wasn't packed or anything
before it was packed
yeah and there's you know it was it was
a good-sized crowd but it wasn't packed
yeah it was it far I had fun though it
is these are always super fun um you
know like I said it's a terrible movie
but that's kind of the whole point yeah
everybody
that watches the chernozem a huge
mystery science theater fan so I love
these shitty movies and I love them
making jokes about it and they usually
also have a short this one has like them
gruff and yeah punctual anti-drug sure I
get a rhythm that is super fine yeah
yeah there were some really really great
jokes in this it's like honestly the
octoman suit was probably the best part
of the movie it wasn't that bad like I
did monster see what was funny about
this movie is that they didn't even try
to make any suspense they showed you
this monster in full during the opening
credits right though there was no just
like it was like there was no suspense
you knew exactly what you were getting
the second this movie starts and then he
says creepin around by yeah you see this
monster through the whole [ __ ] thing
and it looks bad and like a lot of this
movie was dark yeah and right headed if
flashlight and it's like they'd have
like 20 minutes scenes of like a skinny
dude crawling booth cave just keep you
hanging around in front of an RV
drinking coffee yeah [ __ ] like that yeah
but they're they're having a timeout but
their love pads the film yes you can't
keep it there there riff and honor those
so it makes it makes it funny
well yeah that's what I mean is it so
I'm very excited that they started doing
these clothes because I'm really good
now I have to say the AMC Stubbs a list
program this is a special events fathom
events so I have to way to pay X we have
like 13 but yeah we don't we don't get
these ones for free cuz you know we had
a three slot so but this is a special
occasion but like I said if they're
gonna do boot tracks live as you do this
theater right here by our house [ __ ]
yeah you know like I said they do like
for a year they're worth seein because
it kind of has kind of like that live
event feeling to it it's not like
watching
so it's pretty good or is laughing yeah
and it's fun to come with yeah and
they're making us they're making
mistakes live and differ a little with
it yeah yeah that's good they're good
though it's kind of like an advanced
special event they replay him two times
I think they're doing this one because
today's what the hell is today the 17
yeah yeah they're doing another 24 that
usually they do like a repeat and
honestly a lot of them that I've seen a
bunch of them you know what they record
them and they'll put them on like to be
or Hulu has a bunch of them and stuff
like that so you can still see them like
even if you miss them in the theater but
I think it's more fun to see me yeah
soon as soon as you can see them like
with other people yeah yeah there are
something for dressed up and make a show
up in the Google dressed up in goofy
[ __ ] yeah it's nerdy it's alright though
yeah sorry that I'm not I'm seriously
I'm a big dork right yeah all right
okay we just got done seeing la Llorona
which refers the curse of lier on
although I don't think people gonna call
the curse of La Llorona it was a Mexican
ghost story about this scary-looking
mexican chick a bridal gown that comes
and drowns little children according to
the movie it's like a Mexican folk
legend 73 that's when I first the book
that I bring up on the show a lot which
is that strange stories amazing facts I
read it about it yeah it gives a little
history of how she became the the euro
'no the weeping woman and yeah and this
thing comes after and starts killing all
these kids tell you one thing that the
first half of this movie man every time
they show that thing my [ __ ] hairs a
stand up on the back of my neck it was
very effective she'd come up and you
really wouldn't see it real clearly you
have this weird scream kind of mixed
with the sound of kinda like nails on a
chalkboard you know and it was just it
was freaky but you know like the second
half of the movie when you started to
see it more closely I just kinda wasn't
scared of it well they showed it too
much you go oh yeah it's a woman in
makeup and that's exactly what it looks
like
it shouldn't have done that and it
looked too solid yeah it should have
been semi translucent and it should have
been more ghost-like and you really they
should have never uncovered its face it
should they should have kept the face
covered with the damn veil because that
was like something but that was that
scared me when you really couldn't see
its face yeah cuz then you could just
kind of imagine it you can ya and they
should have kept it that way and the way
the movie ends it reminded me at the
tone of the movie towards the end I
started to rhyme if like a cheesy 80s
action flick
I was gonna say reminds now if you
didn't know what I'm sure most people
know this but this was directed by James
Wan it also it's in the same universe as
the conjuring because they made a little
there was a little Easter egg in there
to Annabel so you know so and I think he
kind of obliquely mentioned the Warrens
one time but since this one is set in
Los Angeles and you know not where the
warrant the warrants usual stomping
grounds which even though the conjuring
movies and everything so they weren't in
this one but I think they were obliquely
referenced even that they weren't named
and like I said they did show Annabel
for a second when they were like
referring to one of the other cases um I
I'm not a huge fit like I know James Wan
is like this big like horror behemoth
and everything like that I his movies
are fine um I don't really find them
particularly scary I don't you know
they're fun to watch and stuff like that
but you know I don't consider them great
horror movies I can sit in like workman
like that's almost say and this one was
another one it was fine it was a good
scary yeah it reminded me not fantastic
just it reminded me of like a slight
like a higher production value episode
of a haunting yeah it was a little bit
long it was very much like that if you
knew that then you'd press it was very
straightforward it was basically just
like you know the the myth and then like
they had to hire somebody like to
exorcise the house or whatever like try
to keep my aronia from getting the kids
and that's pretty much the whole story
there wasn't like a lot of other stuff
going on so it's pretty it's pretty
short it was only like an Arab had he
kept the tone more like the first half
and just gone with that I think this
would have been a much better movie yeah
you know he showed it too much and
showed it to clearly that's a mistake
that a lot of yeah I mean you know it's
sometimes you have to show but I think
it's creepier if you just kind of show
it like her hint at it like if you don't
like just like from those phases and
like I said I don't a lot of the jump
scares that are in the movie were in the
trailer so they weren't really
surprising and also I on a on another
note it's like we saw this at like
really late like on Thursday night it's
like the opening night of it tonight
and there were these people in there
that just talked the whole [ __ ] movie
the whole movie they were like talking
and laughs like talking it like normal
yeah like as loud as I'm talking about
louder actually and I just kept turning
around like shut the [ __ ] up shut [ __ ]
up and they would just never show that
[ __ ] up so you know so I couldn't really
concentrate on the movie I feel like
maybe I would have liked it better if
there weren't like a lot of choads like
making noise in the back it was they
were getting scared that's what it was
because when everything cuz you know
when a James Wan movie when everything
goes quiet you know it's gonna be a big
jump scare in a minute and it's like to
me it's like yeah you know there's a
jump scare coming so it wasn't scary but
it's like these people were obviously
really scared and they were just like
okay they were so they wouldn't like
jump yeah yeah they're there you know
yeah 90 90 IQ teachers super [ __ ]
annoying I'm just like you know protip
when you go to a movie you're not you're
[ __ ] living room but okay yes it
wasn't a great movie it is a workmanlike
it was that right it was okay it was
like the nuns ya know what I mean I mean
like I said it's the same universe same
not quite as forgettable as the nun no I
yeah it was a bit better cuz the monster
yeah the monster was better and like I
said that first half I was thinking you
know this is a pretty do good damn yeah
it's creeping me out yeah it was pretty
the kid in the car and it's at the
window and yeah that was pretty weird
screaming that it did and it's you know
I was going this is gonna this is a
pretty [ __ ] freaky ass movie my hair
was standing up on the back of my neck
when it when it was scream like it was
just like an unearthly sounded scream
but then as it went on at kana did they
stopped being artful with this thing
yeah because then you'd just be like oh
wait turn right now and it's a woman in
a costume walking down the hallway
that's all
[Music]